the following content is provided under a Creative Commons license your support
a Creative Commons license your support will help MIT open courseware continue
will help MIT open courseware continue to offer highquality educational
to offer highquality educational resources for free to make a donation or
resources for free to make a donation or view additional materials from hundreds
view additional materials from hundreds of MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware
of MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu today we're going to sort of introduce Graph Search and general and
introduce Graph Search and general and talk about one algorithm which is bread
talk about one algorithm which is bread for search and understand how in
for search and understand how in principle you could solve a puzzle like
principle you could solve a puzzle like the Rubik's Cube uh so before I get to
the Rubik's Cube uh so before I get to Rubik's Cubes let me remind you of some
Rubik's Cubes let me remind you of some some basic stuff about graphs uh or I
some basic stuff about graphs uh or I can tell you to start out with Graph
graph and there's many different Notions of exploring a graph maybe I give you
of exploring a graph maybe I give you some node in graph s and some other node
some node in graph s and some other node in graph T and I'd like to find a
in graph T and I'd like to find a path that's going to represent a problem
path that's going to represent a problem like I give you a particular state of a
like I give you a particular state of a Rubik's Cube and I want to know is there
Rubik's Cube and I want to know is there some path that gets me into a solve
some path that gets me into a solve state do I really want to solve this on
state do I really want to solve this on stage what the hell we
stage what the hell we started all right so this is a
started all right so this is a particularly easy state to solve why I
particularly easy state to solve why I set it up this way all right so there
set it up this way all right so there you go 7 by seven by seven Rubik Cube
you go 7 by seven by seven Rubik Cube solved in 10 seconds
solved in 10 seconds amazing new world
amazing new world record so that you're given some initial
record so that you're given some initial state of the Rubik's Cube you're given
state of the Rubik's Cube you're given the target State you know what solve
the target State you know what solve looks like you want to find this path um
looks like you want to find this path um maybe you want to find all paths from s
maybe you want to find all paths from s maybe you just want to explore all the
maybe you just want to explore all the nodes in a graph you can reach from s
nodes in a graph you can reach from s maybe you want to explore all the nodes
maybe you want to explore all the nodes in a graph or maybe all the edges in the
in a graph or maybe all the edges in the graph these are all exploration problems
graph these are all exploration problems they're all going to be solved by
they're all going to be solved by algorithms from this class and next
algorithms from this class and next class
class um so before we go further though I
um so before we go further though I should remind you what a graph is and
should remind you what a graph is and sort of basic features of graphs that
sort of basic features of graphs that we're going to be using uh this is all
we're going to be using uh this is all 6042 material so you should know it very
6042 material so you should know it very well if you don't there's an appendex in
well if you don't there's an appendex in the textbook about it we have a set of
the textbook about it we have a set of vertices we have a set of edges
items or uh ordered
pairs in this case we call the graph undirected in this case we call the
undirected in this case we call the graph directed usually there's only one
graph directed usually there's only one type either all the edges are directed
type either all the edges are directed or all the edges are
or all the edges are undirected there is a study of graphs
undirected there is a study of graphs that have both but we are not doing that
that have both but we are not doing that here so uh some simple
graph okay the set of vertices here is ABCD set of vertices here is ABC Uh set
ABCD set of vertices here is ABC Uh set of edges here is um so e is going to
of edges here is um so e is going to be things like AB
b c CD I think you get the
idea just for completeness uh V is ABCD just so you remember notation and so
on one of the issues we're going to talk about in this class is how do you
about in this class is how do you represent a graph like this for an
represent a graph like this for an algorithm so it's all fine to say oh
algorithm so it's all fine to say oh this is a set of things this is a set of
this is a set of things this is a set of things an obvious representation is you
things an obvious representation is you have a list or array of vertices you
have a list or array of vertices you have an array of edges each Edge knows
have an array of edges each Edge knows it's two end points that would be a
it's two end points that would be a horrible representation for graph
horrible representation for graph because if you're I don't know you're at
because if you're I don't know you're at vertex a and you want to know what are
vertex a and you want to know what are the neighbors of a b and c you'd have to
the neighbors of a b and c you'd have to go through the entire Edge list to
go through the entire Edge list to figure out the neighbors of a so it's
figure out the neighbors of a so it's spend linear time just to know where you
spend linear time just to know where you can go from a so we're not going to use
can go from a so we're not going to use that representation we're going to use
that representation we're going to use some better
some better representations something called
representations something called adjacency
adjacency lists um cool
lists um cool cool okay over here you've got things
cool okay over here you've got things like
like AC
AC BC and CB so you can have edges in both
BC and CB so you can have edges in both directions what am I missing
case uh there a whole lot of applications of graph
applications of graph search make you a little list talk about
search make you a little list talk about a few of them
crawling uh your Google you want to find all the pages in the web most people
all the pages in the web most people don't just tell you hey I've got a new
don't just tell you hey I've got a new page please index it you have to just
page please index it you have to just keep following links in the early days
keep following links in the early days of the web this was a big deal following
of the web this was a big deal following links finding everything that's out
links finding everything that's out there it's a little bit of an issue
there it's a little bit of an issue because if you define it wrong the
because if you define it wrong the internet is infinite uh because of all
internet is infinite uh because of all this dynamically generated pages but uh
this dynamically generated pages but uh to deal with that Google goes sort of
to deal with that Google goes sort of bread first for the most part it's
bread first for the most part it's prioritized but you from you want to see
prioritized but you from you want to see all the things you can reach from Pages
all the things you can reach from Pages you already have and keep
you already have and keep going at some point you give up when you
going at some point you give up when you run out of time uh social
run out of time uh social networking you're on Facebook use
networking you're on Facebook use FriendFinder tries to find the friends
FriendFinder tries to find the friends that are nearest to you or friends of
that are nearest to you or friends of friends uh is sort of a level to search
friends uh is sort of a level to search that's essentially a graph search
that's essentially a graph search problem you want to
problem you want to know what's two levels or three levels
know what's two levels or three levels of separation from you and then you go
of separation from you and then you go you look Loop over those and look for
you look Loop over those and look for other signs that you might be good
friends uh you're on a network like the internet or some
network like the internet or some internet you want to broadcast a message
internet you want to broadcast a message so here's you you want to send data out
so here's you you want to send data out that's a essentially a graph exploration
that's a essentially a graph exploration problem that message that packet is
problem that message that packet is going to explore the
going to explore the graph
graph uh garbage
collection I hope you all know that uh modern languages have garbage collection
modern languages have garbage collection this is why you don't have to worry
this is why you don't have to worry about freeing things um even in Python
about freeing things um even in Python even in cpython I learned there is a
even in cpython I learned there is a garbage collector as a version two uh
garbage collector as a version two uh but also in piie and uh Python and in
but also in piie and uh Python and in Java and like pretty much every uh
Java and like pretty much every uh fairly modern language you have garbage
fairly modern language you have garbage collection meaning if there's some data
collection meaning if there's some data that's unreachable from so you have your
that's unreachable from so you have your variables whatever is actively in your
variables whatever is actively in your in variables that can be accessed by the
in variables that can be accessed by the program everything that's reachable from
program everything that's reachable from there you have to keep but if some data
there you have to keep but if some data structure becomes no longer reachable
structure becomes no longer reachable you need to you can throw it away and
you need to you can throw it away and regain
regain memory uh and so that's happening behind
memory uh and so that's happening behind the scenes all the time and the way it's
the scenes all the time and the way it's being done is with a bread for search
being done is with a bread for search which is what we're going to talk about
which is what we're going to talk about today uh another one model
checking uh model checking is you have uh some finite model
uh some finite model of either a piece of code or a circuit a
of either a piece of code or a circuit a chip whatever you want to prove that it
chip whatever you want to prove that it actually does what you think it does and
actually does what you think it does and so you've drawn a graph which is the
so you've drawn a graph which is the graph is all the possible states that
graph is all the possible states that your circuit or your computer program
your circuit or your computer program could reach or that it could possibly
could reach or that it could possibly have you start in some initial State and
have you start in some initial State and you want to know among all the states
you want to know among all the states that you can reach does it have some
that you can reach does it have some property and so you want need to visit
property and so you want need to visit all the vertices that are reachable from
all the vertices that are reachable from a particular place to do that and
a particular place to do that and usually people do that using breath
usually people do that using breath first
first search uh I use breath first search a
search uh I use breath first search a lot myself uh to check mathematical
lot myself uh to check mathematical conject stres so if you're a
mathematician and you want you think something is true uh like maybe well
something is true uh like maybe well it's hard to give an example of that uh
it's hard to give an example of that uh but you have you can imagine some graph
but you have you can imagine some graph of all the possible sort of inputs to
of all the possible sort of inputs to that theorem and you will need to check
that theorem and you will need to check them for every possible input this is
them for every possible input this is true typical way to do that is breath
true typical way to do that is breath for searching through that entire graph
for searching through that entire graph of
of States uh usually we're testing finite
States uh usually we're testing finite special cases of a general conjecture
special cases of a general conjecture but if we find a counter example we're
but if we find a counter example we're done don't have to work on it anymore if
done don't have to work on it anymore if we don't find a counter example usually
we don't find a counter example usually then we have to do the mathematics so
then we have to do the mathematics so it's not doesn't solve everything
it's not doesn't solve everything but it's
then the fun thing we're going to talk about a little bit today is if you want
about a little bit today is if you want to solve something like a 2x2x2 Rubik's
to solve something like a 2x2x2 Rubik's Cube optimally you can do that using
Cube optimally you can do that using breath for search and you're going to do
breath for search and you're going to do that on your problem
that on your problem Set uh do solving this one optimally
Set uh do solving this one optimally using breath for search uh would
using breath for search uh would probably W would definitely take more
probably W would definitely take more than the lifetime of the universe so
than the lifetime of the universe so don't try 7 by seven by
don't try 7 by seven by seven leave that to the cubing experts I
seven leave that to the cubing experts I guess uh no I think no one will ever
guess uh no I think no one will ever solve a 7 by S by7 Rubik's Cube
solve a 7 by S by7 Rubik's Cube optimally uh but there are ways to find
optimally uh but there are ways to find a solution just not the best one
a solution just not the best one okay so let me tell you just for fun
okay so let me tell you just for fun it's an
example this pocket Cube which is 2x 2x two Rubik's
two Rubik's Cube uh what we have in mind is it's
Cube uh what we have in mind is it's called the configuration graph or
called the configuration graph or sometimes configuration space but it's a
sometimes configuration space but it's a graph so call it a
graph uh this graph has a Vertex for each possible state
Vertex for each possible state of the
cube so this is a state a little creaky here this is a
state a little creaky here this is a state this is a state this is a state
state this is a state this is a state now now I'm hopelessly lost okay anyone
now now I'm hopelessly lost okay anyone want to work on this
want to work on this Bor no one all right I'll leave it
Bor no one all right I'll leave it unsolved then
unsolved then uh okay so all those are vertices
uh okay so all those are vertices there's actually a lot of vertices there
there's actually a lot of vertices there are 264 million vertices or so uh if you
are 264 million vertices or so uh if you want it's in the side here number of
want it's in the side here number of vertices is something
vertices is something like 8 factorial * 3 to
like 8 factorial * 3 to 8 um and one way to see
so these are uh these
are yeah these are what you might call cuets or cubies I think is standard term
cuets or cubies I think is standard term in Rubik's Cube Land and
in Rubik's Cube Land and so the uh how there's eight of them in a
so the uh how there's eight of them in a 2 x two by two two cubed um you can
2 x two by two two cubed um you can essentially permute those cubies within
essentially permute those cubies within the cube however you like that's 8
the cube however you like that's 8 factorial and then each of them has
factorial and then each of them has three possible twists it could be like
three possible twists it could be like this it could be like this or it could
this it could be like this or it could be like
be like this okay so you've got three for each
this okay so you've got three for each and this is actually an accurate count
and this is actually an accurate count you're not over counting the number of
you're not over counting the number of configurations all of those are at least
configurations all of those are at least in principle conceivable if you take
in principle conceivable if you take apart the cube you can reassemble it in
apart the cube you can reassemble it in each of those States and that number is
each of those States and that number is about uh
about uh 264
million okay which is not so bad for computers you could search that um life
computers you could search that um life is a little bit easier you get to divide
is a little bit easier you get to divide by 24 because there's 24 symmetries of
by 24 because there's 24 symmetries of the Cube 8 * three you can divide by
the Cube 8 * three you can divide by three also because um only a third of
three also because um only a third of the configuration space is actually
the configuration space is actually reachable if you're not allowed to take
reachable if you're not allowed to take the parts apart you have to get there by
the parts apart you have to get there by a motion you can only get to oneir of
a motion you can only get to oneir of the two 2x two by two so it's a little
the two 2x two by two so it's a little bit smaller than that if you're actually
bit smaller than that if you're actually doing a breath for search which is what
doing a breath for search which is what you're going to be doing on your problem
you're going to be doing on your problem set but in any case it's
set but in any case it's feasible uh okay that's vertices and
feasible uh okay that's vertices and should talk about
move every move takes you from one configuration to another you could
configuration to another you could Traverse it in One Direction make that
Traverse it in One Direction make that move you could also undo that move
move you could also undo that move because every move is undoable in a
because every move is undoable in a Rubik's Cube this graph is undirected or
Rubik's Cube this graph is undirected or can think of it as every Edge Works in
can think of it as every Edge Works in both directions so so this is a move
both directions so so this is a move it's called a quarter twist uh some it's
it's called a quarter twist uh some it's a controversy if you will uh some people
a controversy if you will uh some people allow a whole half twist as a single
allow a whole half twist as a single move whether you define that as a single
move whether you define that as a single move or a double move not that big a
move or a double move not that big a deal just changes some of the
deal just changes some of the answers but uh you're still exploring
answers but uh you're still exploring essentially the same
essentially the same graph so that's the graph and you'd like
graph so that's the graph and you'd like to know some properties about it so let
to know some properties about it so let me draw a picture of the graph I'm not
me draw a picture of the graph I'm not going to draw all 264 million vertices
going to draw all 264 million vertices but in particular there's the solved
but in particular there's the solved State we kind of care about that one
State we kind of care about that one where all the colors are
where all the colors are aligned uh then
aligned uh then there's all of the configurations you
there's all of the configurations you could reach by one move so these are the
could reach by one move so these are the possible
possible moves from solve
State and then from those configurations there's more places you can go maybe
there's more places you can go maybe there's multiple ways to get to the same
node okay but these would be all of the configurations you can reach in two
moves okay and so on and at some point you run out of graph so there might be
you run out of graph so there might be some ways to get there might be a few
some ways to get there might be a few things few nodes out here these are kind
things few nodes out here these are kind of the the way I'm drawing this this is
of the the way I'm drawing this this is everything you can reach one move and
everything you can reach one move and two moves and three moves at the end
two moves and three moves at the end this would be 11
this would be 11 moves uh if you if you allow half
moves uh if you if you allow half twists uh and I guess as puzzlers we're
twists uh and I guess as puzzlers we're particularly interested in this number
particularly interested in this number which you would call as a graph theorist
which you would call as a graph theorist the diameter of the
the diameter of the graph puzzlers call it God's number if
graph puzzlers call it God's number if you were God or some uh Omni something
you were God or some uh Omni something being you have the optimal algorithm for
being you have the optimal algorithm for solving the Rubik's Cube how many moves
solving the Rubik's Cube how many moves do do you need if you always follow the
do do you need if you always follow the best path and the answer is in the worst
best path and the answer is in the worst case 11 so we're interested in the worst
case 11 so we're interested in the worst case of the best
case of the best algorithm for 2x 2 x two the answer is
algorithm for 2x 2 x two the answer is 11 for 3x3x3 uh the answer is 20 that
11 for 3x3x3 uh the answer is 20 that was just proved last summer with I don't
was just proved last summer with I don't a couple years of computer time for
a couple years of computer time for 4x4x4 I don't have one here I think
4x4x4 I don't have one here I think we'll never know the answer for 5x 5x5
we'll never know the answer for 5x 5x5 we'll never know the answer for six for
we'll never know the answer for six for seven same deal uh but for 2x two by two
seven same deal uh but for 2x two by two you can compute it you will compute it
you can compute it you will compute it on your problem set and uh it's kind of
on your problem set and uh it's kind of nice to know because it says whatever
nice to know because it says whatever configuration I'm in I can solve it in
configuration I'm in I can solve it in 11
11 moves but the best known way to to
moves but the best known way to to compute it is basically to construct
compute it is basically to construct this graph uh one layer at a time until
this graph uh one layer at a time until you're done and then you know what the
you're done and then you know what the diameter is the trouble is in between
diameter is the trouble is in between here this grows exponentially at some
here this grows exponentially at some point it it decreases a little bit but
point it it decreases a little bit but getting over that exponential hump is
getting over that exponential hump is really hard and for 3x3x3 they used a
really hard and for 3x3x3 they used a lot of tricks to speed up uh the
lot of tricks to speed up uh the algorithm but in the end it's
algorithm but in the end it's essentially a breath first search what's
essentially a breath first search what's a breath first search this going layer
a breath first search this going layer by layer so we're going to formalize
by layer so we're going to formalize that in a
that in a moment uh but that is the problem uh so
moment uh but that is the problem uh so just for fun
and guesses what the right answer is for an N by n byn rubrics Cube what's the
an N by n byn rubrics Cube what's the diameter not an exact answer because I
diameter not an exact answer because I think we'll never know the exact answer
think we'll never know the exact answer but if I want Theta something what do
but if I want Theta something what do you think the something
is how many people here have solved a Rubik's Cube ever okay so you know what
Rubik's Cube ever okay so you know what we're talking about here most people
we're talking about here most people have worked on
it you think about an N byn byn rubrics Cube each side has area n s so total
Cube each side has area n s so total area is surface area is 6 n s so there's
area is surface area is 6 n s so there's roughly Theta n s little QB
roughly Theta n s little QB here so what do you think the right
here so what do you think the right astics is for n by n
n cubed reasonable guess but wrong it's an upper bound why n
cubed oh you're guessing based on the numbers yeah the numbers are misleading
numbers yeah the numbers are misleading unfortunately it's a law of law of small
unfortunately it's a law of law of small numbers I guess doesn't really look
numbers I guess doesn't really look right
right I know the answer I know the answer
I know the answer I know the answer because we just wrote a paper with the
because we just wrote a paper with the answer this is a new result from this
answer this is a new result from this summer but I'm
summer but I'm curious so to me the obvious answer is N
curious so to me the obvious answer is N squared because there's about n squ QB
squared because there's about n squ QB and it's not so hard to show in a
and it's not so hard to show in a constant number of moves you can solve a
constant number of moves you can solve a constant number of qes if you think
constant number of qes if you think about the general algorithms like if
about the general algorithms like if you've ever looked up professor's Cube
you've ever looked up professor's Cube and how to solve it you're doing like 10
and how to solve it you're doing like 10 moves and then you solve maybe swap two
moves and then you solve maybe swap two QBs which you can use to solve
QBs which you can use to solve a couple QBs in a constant number of
a couple QBs in a constant number of moves so N2 would
moves so N2 would be the standard answer if you're
be the standard answer if you're following standard algorithms but it
following standard algorithms but it turns out you can do a little bit better
turns out you can do a little bit better and the right answer is n s divided by
and the right answer is n s divided by log N I think it's cool hopefully you
log N I think it's cool hopefully you guys can appreciate that not a lot of
guys can appreciate that not a lot of people can appreciate n s divided by log
people can appreciate n s divided by log n but here in algorithms we're all about
n but here in algorithms we're all about n s over log
in so if you're interested papers on my website things called
papers on my website things called algorithms for solving Rubik's Cubes
algorithms for solving Rubik's Cubes there's a constant there current
there's a constant there current constant is not so good let's say it's
constant is not so good let's say it's in the
in the millions
millions but hey you got to start somewhere
but hey you got to start somewhere there's the next work the next open
there's the next work the next open problem would be to improve that
problem would be to improve that constant to something reasonable that
constant to something reasonable that maybe is close to 20 but we're far from
maybe is close to 20 but we're far from that okay let's talk about graph
that okay let's talk about graph representation
before we can talk about exploring a graph we need to know what we're given
graph we need to know what we're given as
as input and there's basically one standard
input and there's basically one standard representation and a bunch of variations
representation and a bunch of variations of
of it and they are called adjacency
lists so the idea with an adjacency list is you have an
is you have an array called a DJ for
adjacency of size V each element in the array is a pointer to a link
list and the idea is that this array is indexed by a
Vertex so we're imagining a world where we can index arrays by vertices so maybe
we can index arrays by vertices so maybe you just label your vertices 0 through
you just label your vertices 0 through vus one then that's regular array or if
vus one then that's regular array or if you want to get fancy you can think of a
you want to get fancy you can think of a Vertex as an arbitrary hashable thing
Vertex as an arbitrary hashable thing and AJ is actually a hash table and
and AJ is actually a hash table and that's how you probably do it in Python
that's how you probably do it in Python maybe your vertices are objects and this
maybe your vertices are objects and this is just hashing based on the address of
is just hashing based on the address of the object but we're not going to worry
the object but we're not going to worry about that just going to write adj of
about that just going to write adj of you assume that somehow you can get the
you assume that somehow you can get the link list corresponding with that
link list corresponding with that vertex uh
and the idea is for every vertex we just store its
store its neighbors namely the vertices you can
neighbors namely the vertices you can reach by one step from U so I'm going to
reach by one step from U so I'm going to Define that a little more formally adj
Define that a little more formally adj of U is going to be the set of all
of U is going to be the set of all vertices v such that
vertices v such that UV is an
edge okay so uh if you have a ver vertex where's where are my graphs here so if I
where's where are my graphs here so if I have a Vertex like B AJ of B is going to
have a Vertex like B AJ of B is going to be both A and C because in one step
be both A and C because in one step there are outgoing edges from B to A and
there are outgoing edges from B to A and B to C so AJ of B is a c write
that in that graph I should have labeled the verticy something different uh AJ of
the verticy something different uh AJ of a
a is going to be just C because you can't
is going to be just C because you can't get from one with one step from A to B
get from one with one step from A to B there's the edges in the wrong
there's the edges in the wrong direction okay and agj of
direction okay and agj of C is
B okay I think that definition is pretty clear for undirected graphs you just put
clear for undirected graphs you just put braces here which means you store I mean
braces here which means you store I mean it's same thing for here adj of C is
it's same thing for here adj of C is going to be a b and d because you can
going to be a b and d because you can get in one step from C to a from C to B
get in one step from C to a from C to B from C to D this for pretty much every
from C to D this for pretty much every at least for graph exploration problems
at least for graph exploration problems this is the representation you want
this is the representation you want because you're at some vertex you want
because you're at some vertex you want to know where can I go next and adj of
to know where can I go next and adj of that vertex tells you exactly where you
that vertex tells you exactly where you can go next so this is what you
can go next so this is what you want
want um there's a lot of different ways to
um there's a lot of different ways to actually Implement adjacency
actually Implement adjacency lists I've talked about two of them
lists I've talked about two of them you could have the vertices labeled 0 to
you could have the vertices labeled 0 to V minus one and then this is literally
V minus one and then this is literally an array and you have I guess I should
an array and you have I guess I should draw uh in this
draw uh in this picture
picture adj is an array so you've got a B and C
adj is an array so you've got a B and C each one of them is a pointer to a link
each one of them is a pointer to a link list this one's actually going to be
list this one's actually going to be a c and we're done this one is oh sorry
a c and we're done this one is oh sorry that was B
that was B B who said it had to be alphabetical
B who said it had to be alphabetical order uh a is pointer to c c is a
order uh a is pointer to c c is a pointer to B okay that's explicitly how
pointer to B okay that's explicitly how you might represent it this might be a
you might represent it this might be a hash table instead of an array if you
hash table instead of an array if you have weirder vertices uh you can also do
have weirder vertices uh you can also do it in a more objectoriented
fashion you could for every vertex V you could make ver V the vertices object X
could make ver V the vertices object X and v.
neighbors could store uh a what were defining over there to be adj of V okay
defining over there to be adj of V okay this would be the more objectoriented
this would be the more objectoriented way to do it I've thought a lot about
way to do it I've thought a lot about this and I like this and usually when I
this and I like this and usually when I Implement graphs this is what I do uh
Implement graphs this is what I do uh but it is actually it's convenient to
but it is actually it's convenient to have this representation and there's a
have this representation and there's a reason the textbook uses this
reason the textbook uses this representation because if you've already
representation because if you've already got some vertices lying around and you
got some vertices lying around and you want to have multiple graphs on those
want to have multiple graphs on those vertices this lets you do
vertices this lets you do that you can Define multiple adj arrays
that you can Define multiple adj arrays one for graph one one for graph two one
one for graph one one for graph two one for graph three they could all talk
for graph three they could all talk about the same vertices whereas here
about the same vertices whereas here vertex can only sort of belong to one
vertex can only sort of belong to one graph it can only have one neighbor
graph it can only have one neighbor structure that says what happens if
structure that says what happens if you're only dealing with one graph this
you're only dealing with one graph this is probably cleaner but with multiple
is probably cleaner but with multiple graphs which will happen even in this
graphs which will happen even in this class uh adjacent C lists are kind of
class uh adjacent C lists are kind of the way to go uh you can also do
the way to go uh you can also do implicitly represented
graphs which would be to say uh adj of U is a
is a method of the vertex class okay meaning it's not just stored
class okay meaning it's not just stored there explicitly whenever you need it
there explicitly whenever you need it you call this function and it computes
you call this function and it computes what you
what you want uh this is useful because it uses
want uh this is useful because it uses less space you could say this uses zero
less space you could say this uses zero space or maybe V space for one fre
space or maybe V space for one fre vertex depends maybe you don't even need
vertex depends maybe you don't even need to explicitly represent all the
to explicitly represent all the vertices you start with some vertex and
vertices you start with some vertex and given a Vertex somehow you know how to
given a Vertex somehow you know how to compute let's say in constant time or
compute let's say in constant time or linear time or something the neighbors
linear time or something the neighbors of that
of that vertex and then from there you can keep
vertex and then from there you can keep keep searching keep Computing neighbors
keep searching keep Computing neighbors until you find what you want maybe you
until you find what you want maybe you don't have to build the whole graph you
don't have to build the whole graph you just need to build build enough of it
just need to build build enough of it till you find your answer whatever
till you find your answer whatever answer you're searching for you think of
answer you're searching for you think of a situation where that might be the
case where implicit representation would be a good idea yeah Rubik's Cubes you're
be a good idea yeah Rubik's Cubes you're really good I never want to build this
really good I never want to build this space it has a bajillion States
space it has a bajillion States bajillion vertices I it would take
bajillion vertices I it would take forever there's more configurations of
forever there's more configurations of this Cube than there are particles in
this Cube than there are particles in the known
the known universe yeah just computed that in my
universe yeah just computed that in my head I I have done this computation
head I I have done this computation recently and for 5x 5 by5 it's like 10
recently and for 5x 5 by5 it's like 10 to the 40 States or 10 to the somewhere
to the 40 States or 10 to the somewhere 10 to the 40 10 to the 60 there's about
10 to the 40 10 to the 60 there's about 10 80 particles in the non Universe 10
10 80 particles in the non Universe 10 83 or something so this is probably I
83 or something so this is probably I don't know 10 the 200 or so it's a lot
don't know 10 the 200 or so it's a lot you never want to build that but it's
you never want to build that but it's very easy to represent this state just
very easy to represent this state just Store where all the QB are and it's very
Store where all the QB are and it's very easy to see what are all the
easy to see what are all the configurations you can reach in one move
configurations you can reach in one move just try this move try this move try
just try this move try this move try this move put it back then try the next
this move put it back then try the next move and so on so in you know time for
move and so on so in you know time for an N byn byn cube in order n time you
an N byn byn cube in order n time you can list all the order end next States
can list all the order end next States you can list all the order and neighbors
you can list all the order and neighbors and so you could keep exploring
and so you could keep exploring searching for your state now you don't
searching for your state now you don't want to explore too far for that Cube
want to explore too far for that Cube but uh at least you're not you're not
but uh at least you're not you're not hosed just from the problem of
hosed just from the problem of representing the graph so even for 2 by
representing the graph so even for 2 by two x two it's useful to do this mostly
two x two it's useful to do this mostly to save space you're not really saving
to save space you're not really saving time but you don't you'd like to not
time but you don't you'd like to not have to store all 264 million States
have to store all 264 million States because it's going to be several
because it's going to be several gigabytes and
gigabytes and it's
it's annoying uh speaking of space ignoring
annoying uh speaking of space ignoring the implicit representation how much
the implicit representation how much space does this representation
require V plus e this is going to be our the bread and butter of our graph
the bread and butter of our graph algorithms most of the things we're
algorithms most of the things we're going to talk about achieve V plus e
going to talk about achieve V plus e time this is essentially optimal is
time this is essentially optimal is linear in the size of your graph got V
linear in the size of your graph got V vertices e edges technically if in case
vertices e edges technically if in case you're curious uh this is really the
you're curious uh this is really the size of V plus the size of e but in the
size of V plus the size of e but in the textbook uh and I guess in the world we
textbook uh and I guess in the world we just admit those sizes of whenever
just admit those sizes of whenever they're in a Theta notation or bigo
they're in a Theta notation or bigo notation so number of vertices plus
notation so number of vertices plus number of edges that's sort of the bare
number of edges that's sort of the bare minimum you need if you want an explicit
minimum you need if you want an explicit representation of the graph and we
representation of the graph and we achieve that because we've got V space
achieve that because we've got V space just to store the vertices in an array
just to store the vertices in an array and then if you add up all each of these
and then if you add up all each of these as an
as an edge uh I have to be a little careful in
edge uh I have to be a little careful in undirected graphs each of these is a
undirected graphs each of these is a half Edge so there's actually two times
half Edge so there's actually two times e nodes over here but it's Theta e so
e nodes over here but it's Theta e so Theta V plus e is the amount of space we
Theta V plus e is the amount of space we need and ideally all our algorithms will
need and ideally all our algorithms will run in this much time that that's what
run in this much time that that's what all you that's what you need just to
all you that's what you need just to look at the
so let's do an actual algorithm is bread for
search so the simplest algorithm you can think of in graphs I've already outlined
think of in graphs I've already outlined it several times you start at some node
it several times you start at some node you look at all the nodes you can get to
you look at all the nodes you can get to from there you look at all the nodes you
from there you look at all the nodes you can get to from there keep going until
can get to from there keep going until you're done so this is going to explore
you're done so this is going to explore all of the vertices that are reachable
all of the vertices that are reachable from a
from a node uh the challenge the one annoying
node uh the challenge the one annoying thing about breath first search and why
thing about breath first search and why this is not trivial is that there can be
this is not trivial is that there can be some edges uh that go sort of
some edges uh that go sort of backwards like
backwards like that to some previous
that to some previous layer uh actually that's not true is it
this can't happen you see why because if that if that edge existed
why because if that if that edge existed then from this node you'd be able to get
then from this node you'd be able to get here so in an undirected graph that
here so in an undirected graph that can't happen in a directed graph you
can't happen in a directed graph you could conceivably have a back Edge like
could conceivably have a back Edge like that you have to realize oh that's a
that you have to realize oh that's a Vertex I've already seen I don't want to
Vertex I've already seen I don't want to put it here even though it's something I
put it here even though it's something I can reach from this node because I've
can reach from this node because I've already been there so you've got to
already been there so you've got to worry about things like that uh yeah
worry about things like that uh yeah that's I guess the main thing to worry
nodes vertices reachable
reachable from given node
s uh we want to achieve V plus e time
to look at the nodes that are reachable uh first in Zero
reachable uh first in Zero moves Zero moves that's
moves Zero moves that's s uh then in one
s uh then in one move well that's uh everything you can
move well that's uh everything you can reach from s in one step that's
reach from s in one step that's adjacency of s and then two moves and
adjacency of s and then two moves and three moves and so on until we run out
three moves and so on until we run out of
of graph okay but we need to be
careful to avoid
avoid uh duplicates we want to avoid
uh duplicates we want to avoid revisiting vertices for a couple reasons
revisiting vertices for a couple reasons one is if we didn't we would spend
one is if we didn't we would spend infinite time because we'd just go there
infinite time because we'd just go there and come back and go there and come back
and come back and go there and come back as long as there's at least one cycle
as long as there's at least one cycle you're going to keep going around the
you're going to keep going around the cycle forever and ever if you don't try
cycle forever and ever if you don't try to avoid
to avoid duplicates all right so let me write
duplicates all right so let me write down some code for this algorithm it's
down some code for this algorithm it's pretty straightforward but so
pretty straightforward but so straightforward we can be completely
straightforward we can be completely explicit and write sud
code there's a few different ways to implement this algorithm I'll show you
implement this algorithm I'll show you my favorite but textbook has a different
my favorite but textbook has a different favorite
I'm going to write in pure python I believe
think I got that right so this is at the end of the while
end of the while loop okay at that point we should be
loop okay at that point we should be done uh we could do an actual example
done uh we could do an actual example Maybe
I'm going to do it on a direct uh sorry an undirected graph but this algorithm
an undirected graph but this algorithm works just as well on directed and
works just as well on directed and undirected graphs
okay there's an undirected graph uh we we're given some start vertex
we're given some start vertex s and we're given the graph by being
s and we're given the graph by being given the adjacency lists so you could
given the adjacency lists so you could iterate over the vertices of that thing
iterate over the vertices of that thing given a Vertex you can list all the
given a Vertex you can list all the edges you can reach in one
edges you can reach in one step and then the top of the algorithm
step and then the top of the algorithm is just some
is just some initialization the basic structure we
initialization the basic structure we have this thing called the frontier
have this thing called the frontier which is uh what we just reached on the
which is uh what we just reached on the previous level
previous level uh I think that's going to be
uh I think that's going to be level I minus one just don't want to
level I minus one just don't want to make an index
make an index error these are going to be all the
error these are going to be all the things you can reach using exactly IUS
things you can reach using exactly IUS one moves and then next is going to be
one moves and then next is going to be all the things you can reach in IM
all the things you can reach in IM moves okay so to get started what we
moves okay so to get started what we know is s s is what you can reach in
know is s s is what you can reach in Zero moves
Zero moves so we set the level of s to be zero
so we set the level of s to be zero that's the first line of the code
that's the first line of the code there's this other thing called a parent
there's this other thing called a parent we'll worry about that later it's
we'll worry about that later it's optional just it gives us some other fun
optional just it gives us some other fun structure uh we set I to be one because
structure uh we set I to be one because we just finished level zero Frontier at
we just finished level zero Frontier at of uh what you can reach in level zero
of uh what you can reach in level zero is just s itself so we're going to put
is just s itself so we're going to put that in a list that is level zero I
that in a list that is level zero I equal 1 so 1 - 1 is Z all good and then
equal 1 so 1 - 1 is Z all good and then we're going to iterate and this is going
we're going to iterate and this is going to be looking at the the end of the
to be looking at the the end of the iteration is to increment I so you could
iteration is to increment I so you could also call this a for Loop except we
also call this a for Loop except we don't know when it's going to end so
don't know when it's going to end so it's easier to think of I incrementing
it's easier to think of I incrementing each step not knowing when we're going
each step not knowing when we're going to stop we're going to stop whenever we
to stop we're going to stop whenever we run out of nodes so whenever Frontier is
run out of nodes so whenever Frontier is a non-empty list and the bulk of the
a non-empty list and the bulk of the work here is Computing what the next
work here is Computing what the next level is that's called Next it's going
level is that's called Next it's going to be level I we do some computation
to be level I we do some computation eventually we have what's on the next
eventually we have what's on the next level then we set Frontier to next
level then we set Frontier to next so because that's our new level we
so because that's our new level we increment I and that invariant of
increment I and that invariant of Frontier being level IUS one is
Frontier being level IUS one is preserved right after here and then we
preserved right after here and then we just keep going till we run out of
just keep going till we run out of nodes uh how do we compute next well we
nodes uh how do we compute next well we look at every node in the frontier and
look at every node in the frontier and we look at all the nodes you can reach
we look at all the nodes you can reach from those nodes so every node you in
from those nodes so every node you in the frontier and then we look at uh so
the frontier and then we look at uh so this means there's an edge from U to
this means there's an edge from U to V so the picture we look at all the
V so the picture we look at all the edges from all the frontier nodes where
edges from all the frontier nodes where you can go and then the key thing is we
you can go and then the key thing is we check for duplicates we see have we seen
check for duplicates we see have we seen this node before if we have we would
this node before if we have we would have set its level to be something if we
have set its level to be something if we haven't seen it it will not be in the
haven't seen it it will not be in the level hash table the level dictionary
level hash table the level dictionary and so if it's not in there uh we'll put
and so if it's not in there uh we'll put it in there and add it to the next layer
it in there and add it to the next layer so that's how you avoid duplicates you
so that's how you avoid duplicates you set its level to make sure you will
set its level to make sure you will never visit it again you add it to the
never visit it again you add it to the next Frontier you iterate you're
next Frontier you iterate you're done okay uh this is one version of what
done okay uh this is one version of what you might call breath for search and it
you might call breath for search and it achieves this goal visiting all the
achieves this goal visiting all the nodes reachable from s in linear time
nodes reachable from s in linear time let's see how it works on a real example
let's see how it works on a real example so first Frontier is this
so first Frontier is this thing uh Frontier just has the node s so
thing uh Frontier just has the node s so we just look at s and we look at all the
we just look at s and we look at all the edges from s we get a and X so those get
edges from s we get a and X so those get added to the next Frontier uh maybe
added to the next Frontier uh maybe before I go too
before I go too far let me switch
colors multimedia here right so here's level
level one all of these guys have uh we're
one all of these guys have uh we're going to set their level to one they can
going to set their level to one they can be reached in one step that's pretty
be reached in one step that's pretty clear so now Frontier is a and X we go
clear so now Frontier is a and X we go to that's what next becomes then
to that's what next becomes then Frontier becomes next and so we look at
Frontier becomes next and so we look at all the edges from a uh that's going to
all the edges from a uh that's going to be S and z s we've already looked at it
be S and z s we've already looked at it already has a level set so we ignore
already has a level set so we ignore that so we look at z z does not have a
that so we look at z z does not have a level indicated here so we're going to
level indicated here so we're going to set it to I which happens to be two at
set it to I which happens to be two at this point and we look at X it has
this point and we look at X it has neighbors s d and c we look at s again
neighbors s d and c we look at s again we say oh we've already seen that yet
we say oh we've already seen that yet again so we're worried about this taking
again so we're worried about this taking a lot of time because we look at S three
a lot of time because we look at S three times in total uh then we look at D D
times in total uh then we look at D D hasn't been set so we set it to two c
hasn't been set so we set it to two c hasn't been set so we set it to two so
hasn't been set so we set it to two so the frontier at level
the frontier at level two is
two is that okay then we look at all the
that okay then we look at all the neighbors of Z there's a A's already
neighbors of Z there's a A's already been set look at all the neighbors of D
been set look at all the neighbors of D there's X there's c those have been set
there's X there's c those have been set there's F this one gets added um then we
there's F this one gets added um then we look at C there's X that's been done D's
look at C there's X that's been done D's been done F's been done V has not been
been done F's been done V has not been done so this becomes a frontier at level
done so this becomes a frontier at level three
three then we look at level three there's F
then we look at level three there's F B's been done C's been done V's been
B's been done C's been done V's been done we look at V C's been done F's been
done we look at V C's been done F's been done nothing to add to next next becomes
done nothing to add to next next becomes empty Frontier becomes empty the Y Loop
empty Frontier becomes empty the Y Loop finishes Tada we've computed we visited
finishes Tada we've computed we visited all the vertices
yeah what this is python notation you may have heard of python uh this is is
may have heard of python uh this is is um a dictionary who's which has one key
um a dictionary who's which has one key value s and has one value zero so you
value s and has one value zero so you could you could yeah that's shorthand in
could you could yeah that's shorthand in Python for uh usually you have a comma
Python for uh usually you have a comma separated list the colon is uh
separated list the colon is uh specifying key value
pairs okay I didn't talk about parent we can do that a little bit uh so
parent we can do that a little bit uh so parent we're initializing to say parent
parent we're initializing to say parent of s is nobody
of s is nobody and then whenever we visit a new vertex
and then whenever we visit a new vertex V we said it's parent to be the vertex
V we said it's parent to be the vertex that we came from so we had this vertex
that we came from so we had this vertex V we had an edge to V from some vertex U
V we had an edge to V from some vertex U we set the parent of V to be U so let me
we set the parent of V to be U so let me add in what that becomes we'll change
add in what that becomes we'll change colors yet
colors yet again although it gets hard to see any
again although it gets hard to see any color but red um let's see so we
color but red um let's see so we have S when we visited a then
have S when we visited a then the parent of a would become s uh when
the parent of a would become s uh when we visited Z the parent of Z would be a
we visited Z the parent of Z would be a uh parent of X is going to be S parent
uh parent of X is going to be S parent of D is going to be X parent of C is
of D is going to be X parent of C is going to be x uh parent of f it could
going to be x uh parent of f it could have been either way but the way I did
have been either way but the way I did it D went
it D went first and so that became its parent and
first and so that became its parent and I think v c was its
I think v c was its parent okay so that's what the parent
parent okay so that's what the parent pointers will look like they always
pointers will look like they always follow edges they actually follow edges
follow edges they actually follow edges backwards if this was a directed graph
backwards if this was a directed graph graph might be directed that way but the
graph might be directed that way but the parent pointers go back along the edges
parent pointers go back along the edges so it's a way to return it's a way to
so it's a way to return it's a way to return to
return to S if you follow these pointers all roads
S if you follow these pointers all roads lead to
lead to S okay um because we started at s that's
S okay um because we started at s that's the property we have in fact these
the property we have in fact these pointers always form a tree and the root
pointers always form a tree and the root of the tree is s in fact these pointers
of the tree is s in fact these pointers form what are called shortest paths let
form what are called shortest paths let me write down a little bit
node and you take it's parent you take the parent or the parent and so on
the parent or the parent and so on eventually you get to S and if you read
eventually you get to S and if you read it
it backwards that will actually be a path
backwards that will actually be a path in the graph and it will be a shortest
in the graph and it will be a shortest path in the
V meaning if you look at all paths in the graph that go from s to V so say
the graph that go from s to V so say we're going from s to V how about that
we're going from s to V how about that uh we compute this shortest we compute
uh we compute this shortest we compute this path out of BFS which is follow
this path out of BFS which is follow parent of V is C parent of C is X parent
parent of V is C parent of C is X parent of X is s
of X is s read it backwards that gives us a path
read it backwards that gives us a path from s Tov uh the claim is that is the
from s Tov uh the claim is that is the shortest way to get from s Tov might not
shortest way to get from s Tov might not be the only one like if you're going
be the only one like if you're going from s to F there's two short paths
from s to F there's two short paths there's this one of length three there's
there's this one of length three there's this one of length three uses three
this one of length three uses three edges same length uh and in the parent
edges same length uh and in the parent pointers we can only afford to encode
pointers we can only afford to encode one of those paths because in general
one of those paths because in general there might be exponentially many ways
there might be exponentially many ways to get from one node to another we find
to get from one node to another we find a shortest path not necessarily the only
a shortest path not necessarily the only one and the length of that
one and the length of that path so shortest here means that you use
path so shortest here means that you use the fewest edges and the length will be
the fewest edges and the length will be uh level of V that's what we're keeping
uh level of V that's what we're keeping track
track of the level's zero you can get there
of the level's zero you can get there with zero steps if the level is one you
with zero steps if the level is one you can get there with one steps because
can get there with one steps because we're visiting everything you can
we're visiting everything you can possibly get in K steps the level is
possibly get in K steps the level is telling you what that shortest path
telling you what that shortest path distance is and the parent pointers are
distance is and the parent pointers are actually giving you the shortest path
actually giving you the shortest path that's the cool thing about BFS yeah BFS
that's the cool thing about BFS yeah BFS explores a vertices sometimes that's all
explores a vertices sometimes that's all you care about but in some sense what
you care about but in some sense what really matters is it finds the shortest
really matters is it finds the shortest way to get from anywhere to anywhere for
way to get from anywhere to anywhere for Rubik's Cube that's nice because you run
Rubik's Cube that's nice because you run the shortest path you run BFS from the
the shortest path you run BFS from the start state of Rubik's Cube then you say
start state of Rubik's Cube then you say oh I'm in this state you look up this
oh I'm in this state you look up this state you look at its level it says oh
state you look at its level it says oh you can get there in nine steps that's I
you can get there in nine steps that's I think the average so I'm guessing I
think the average so I'm guessing I don't know how to do this in nine steps
don't know how to do this in nine steps um and and then uh great so now you know
um and and then uh great so now you know how to solve it you just look at the
how to solve it you just look at the parent pointer the parent pointer gives
parent pointer the parent pointer gives you another configuration to see oh what
you another configuration to see oh what move was that and then you do that move
move was that and then you do that move I'm not going to solve it then you look
I'm not going to solve it then you look at the parent pointer of that you do
at the parent pointer of that you do that move look at the parent pointer of
that move look at the parent pointer of that you do that move eventually you
that you do that move eventually you will get to the solve State and you will
will get to the solve State and you will do it using the fewest possible moves so
do it using the fewest possible moves so if you can afford to put the whole graph
if you can afford to put the whole graph in
in memory which you can't for big Rubik's
memory which you can't for big Rubik's Cube but you can for a small one then
Cube but you can for a small one then this will give you the a strategy the
this will give you the a strategy the optimal strateg
optimal strateg God's algorithm if you will for uh every
God's algorithm if you will for uh every configuration it solves all of them
configuration it solves all of them which is great uh what is the running
which is great uh what is the running time of this algorithm I claim its order
time of this algorithm I claim its order V plus e uh but it looked a little
V plus e uh but it looked a little wasteful because it was checking
wasteful because it was checking vertices over and over and over but if
vertices over and over and over but if you think about it carefully you're only
you think about it carefully you're only looking it's the right way to say this
looking it's the right way to say this uh you only check every Edge once or in
uh you only check every Edge once or in undirected graphs you check them twice
undirected graphs you check them twice once from each side when I visit a
once from each side when I visit a Vertex enters the frontier only once
Vertex enters the frontier only once because once it's in the frontier it
because once it's in the frontier it gets a level Set uh and once it has a
gets a level Set uh and once it has a level set it'll never go in
level set it'll never go in again it'll never get added to
again it'll never get added to next so you know s gets added once then
next so you know s gets added once then we check all the neighbors of s a gets
we check all the neighbors of s a gets added once then we check all the
added once then we check all the neighbors of a x each of these guys gets
neighbors of a x each of these guys gets added once we check all the neighbors so
added once we check all the neighbors so the total running time is going to be
the total running time is going to be the sum over all vertices of the size of
the sum over all vertices of the size of the adjacency list of
the adjacency list of V so this is the number of neighbors
V so this is the number of neighbors that V has and this is going to
that V has and this is going to be
answer number of edges sorry double the number of edges twice the number of
number of edges twice the number of edges for undirected graphs it's going
edges for undirected graphs it's going to be the number of edges for director
to be the number of edges for director graphs this is the handshaking Lemma if
graphs this is the handshaking Lemma if you don't remember the hand shaking
you don't remember the hand shaking Lemma you should read the textbook just
Lemma you should read the textbook just double
double uh 6042
stuff CU you basically you visit every Edge
Edge twice uh for directed graphs you visit
twice uh for directed graphs you visit every Edge
every Edge once but it's order e we also spend
once but it's order e we also spend order V because we touch every vertex uh
order V because we touch every vertex uh so total running time is order V plus e
so total running time is order V plus e uh in fact the way this is going uh you
uh in fact the way this is going uh you can be a little tighter and say it's
can be a little tighter and say it's order E I just want to mention in
order E I just want to mention in reality
reality sometimes you don't care about just what
sometimes you don't care about just what you can reach from s you really want to
you can reach from s you really want to visit every vertex then you need another
visit every vertex then you need another outer loop that's iterating over all the
outer loop that's iterating over all the vertices as potential choices for
vertices as potential choices for S and you then can visit all the
S and you then can visit all the vertices in the entire graph even if
vertices in the entire graph even if it's disconnected we'll talk more about
it's disconnected we'll talk more about that next class that's it for BFS